kerry la manifestation elle a déjà
commencé quelle est l'ambiance sur place
raconte et non un petit peu alors là
actuellement le cortège se trouve aux
liens au niveau de la rue du
faubourg-saint-antoine elle a pris un
peu de retard cette manifestation
puisque tout à l'heure au niveau du
quartier reuilly diderot ils se sont le
cortège s'est arrêté durant plusieurs
minutes au niveau de plusieurs
supermarchés ou leschi les jeunes
voulaient se ravitailler en eau ce qui
n'a pas été possible puisque les gérants
des supermarchés ont fermé les rideaux
de l'établissement donc les gilet jaune
n'ont pas pu y pénétrer il y a eu
quelques échauffourées avec les forces
de l'ordre qui ont ensuite de procéder à
l on laisser rentrer quelques gilet
jaune dans un supermarché à une centaine
de mètres de là et depuis eh bien tout
s'est calmé le cortège avance assez
rapidement et tranquillement en
direction de la place de la nation où
ils devraient arriver d'ici une heure
environ puisqu'il a pris un peu de
retard et que nous trouvons actuellement
rue du faubourg-saint-antoine juste au
niveau de la place de la bastille karine
côté gauche merci pour toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouvera un peu
plus tard